schauen wir auf neue corona regeln für
deutschland für diesen herbst und winter
gerade eben beschlossen vom kabinett
verkündet von karl lauterbach und
fdp-justizminister marco buschmann der
ja der im november letzten jahres doch
eigentlich noch das hier versprochen
hatte
sondern es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
tja das geht jetzt nicht mehr jetzt die
neuen maßnahmen vor allem dann die
masken pflicht die spielt im herbst
wieder eine ganz große rolle masken
pflicht im flieger wird verschärft
medizinische maske reicht jetzt nicht
mehr ab jetzt muss sf sp2 seien es
selber denn in der bahn und auch in den
innenräumen bekommen die länder wieder
das recht überall masken pflichten
durchzusetzen genauso bei größeren
veranstaltungen draußen ja das hat karl
lauterbach eben gerade dazu gesagt
bundesweit so daher ab dem ersten
jahrzehnten gelten dass also in den kern
und im flugverkehr fb2 masken getragen
werden müssen das also in krankenhäusern
und pflegeeinrichtungen
die schutzniveaus erhöht werden dass
dort die rzb zwei masken geht uns
darüber hinaus getestet wird also im
vergleich zum letzten jahr erhöhen wir
dort die aus der schutzmaßnahmen noch
einmal
also schauen wir uns einmal einen
überblick über die neuen regeln dann am
herbst seine gesundheitsminister der
fürchtet eine große welle was also kommt
da alles auf uns zu wäre es bereits
gesagt etwa 42 pflicht in den fernzügen
und flugzeugen masken und testpflicht in
kliniken und pflegeheimen möglich ist
masken pflicht in bussen bahnen und in
innenräumen möglich ist auch masken und
testpflicht für schüler und möglich sind
auch obergrenzen restaurants kneipen und
kinos all das womöglich steht bedeutet
das entscheiden die bundesländer
ja und gleichzeitig gibt es eine große
diskussion gerade bundeskanzler scholz
nämlich der war im flieger ohne maske
das ist auch alles okay so das ist alles
richtig so aber was löst man damit aus
mit solchen bildern der regierungs flug
von scholz & harbeck nach kanada also
die regierung der sich längst von der
maske pflicht befreit dort im
regierungsflieger gilt keine masken
pflicht mehr für die gelten also
sonderregeln extrawürste man den
eindruck und auch darauf wurde karl
lauterbach angesprochen und dass das ist
eine antwort auf
es gibt eigene regen fiel luftwaffe also
wie kann denn das sein also das ist das
sozusagen das rechtfertigt
ja es ist ebenso es gibt eigene regeln
für die luftwaffe und für die
flugbereitschaft und die sind hier zur
zum einsatz gekommen und über diese
regeln hinaus hintern diejenigen die
mitgereisten noch getestet worden ja das
ist ebenso fertig aus darüber müssen wir
sprechen sebastian geisler aus unserem
politik ressort ist hier bei mir im
studio schön dass du hier ist sebastian
denn gerade die serien den neuen regeln
das heißt auch vor allem eins maske
maske maske und gesagt herr lauterbach
zu ausnahmen für politikern naja es ist
ebenso es gelten da üben eigene regeln
für die luftwaffe ich hab's mal
mitgemacht hat sich mal ausgedacht die
bundeswehr schreibt auf ihrer eigenen
website muss man sich auf der zunge
zergehen lassen der militärische
flugbetrieb und dazu zählt ja auch die
luftwaffe unterliegt grundsätzlich
denselben gesetzen und vorschriften wie
die allgemeine zivile luft betrieb so
und jetzt ist es aber ja so für uns wird
die regel sogar verschärft wir müssen
künftig nicht mehr nur reicht diese op
masken die man so vom zahnarzt kind
reicht die mir auf flügel sondern es
muss die ft2 maske sein das hat die
politik verschärft für uns die regeln
wofür sich selbst heißt es dann an über
die bei der luftwaffe also die
hygienemaßnahmen an bord der
flugbereitschaft regelt ein geschwader
befehl heißt es dass er militärisch zu
sagen und dann begeht eben für eine
chance für ihn habe ich irgendwie naja
muss man eben kann man die maske
weglassen wenn man getestet ist das ist
da bin ich auf der zinne dass man hier
so unterschiedlich mit zweierlei maß
misst die politiker können für sich eine
eigene eine ausnahmeregel schaffen und
wir müssen sogar mit unter den
verschärften regeln jetzt leiden vor
allem dann wenn nach erklärungen dafür
gefragt dass die antwort bereit zu haben
das ist eben so ist glaube ich in einer
situation der herbst der vor der türe
und steht der gesundheitsminister der
befürchtet das wird eine ganz ganz große
welle
erzeugen eine große gewinner wähle die
da auf uns zurollt nicht unbedingt das
signal dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger
aus der politik hören wollen denn die
frage war erwartbar da hätte man doch
als gesundheitsminister eine vernünftige
antwort drauf haben müssen eher
verschärft für uns obwohl es ja die
diskussion heute morgen schon gab
gestern eigentlich schon gab als wir
diese bilder gesehen haben dass aus der
kanzlermaschine da war ja schon da
hatten die leute ja schon puls und jetzt
kommt dann die frage moment mal sie
verschärfen also für uns alle diese
regeln und die politiker werden davon
ausgehen kann ich das auch durch ich
ebenso also da krieg ich puls und einen
eindruck den man auch gewonnen hat in
dieser pressekonferenz man hat ja schon
versucht das ganz positive zu betont man
hat gesagt wir wollen ja keine
schulschließung man machen wir wollen
keinen lockdown machen das hat man sich
also ganz groß auf die fahne geschrieben
und gleichzeitig hat man aber einen ganz
großen instrumentenkasten bereitgelegt
und den ländern ganz viele kompetenzen
eine hand zu geben und man weiß gar
nicht so richtig was wird denn jetzt
geld man steht vor der frage was ist
denn jetzt wenn ich ins krankenhaus gehe
oder was ist denn jetzt wenn ich ins
restaurant geht das wird ein absoluter
flickenteppich oder die mehr habe wobei
lauterbach ja sogar sagt weil die länder
werden wahrscheinlich da seinen ganzen
empfehlung seinem seinen vorgaben folgen
und dann wird das möglicherweise relativ
einheitlich sein sagt er weil er nämlich
wolf hofft sozusagen das möglichst
scharfe regeln jetzt in den ländern
kommen und tatsächlich läuft es
wahrscheinlich raus auf die faustregel
wenn ich jetzt restaurant will was weiß
ich theater ins kino und so überall am
eingang dann wieder muss ich die maske
aufsetzen die dann rein kann am tisch
dann abnehmen und so das ist das was wir
kennen wo wir dachten oder wo auch unser
gesund sagt justizminister der buschmann
ich versprochen hat dass das vorbei sein
sollte das kommt jetzt alles wieder
schlechte nachrichten
wir blicken in diesem herbst schauen was
da kommen freuen uns dass heute noch
sommer ist sebastian geisler vielen dank
für deinen besuch hier bei uns im studio
[Musik]